here's a newsweek story aoc slams tucker
carlson as trash
after he calls her rich white lady
representative aoc has referred to fox
and so tucker carlson as a creep after
he falsely claimed that she was not a
person of color but instead of rich and
title white lady carson insisted
that aoc was white despite her shade
while discussing the upcoming book take
up space the unprecedented aoc carlson
took exception to the book books author
writing that the congresswoman had fully
out loud white female
asking whether they are referring to a
trans thing because arguing that no one
has done more personally to the great
american womanhood aoc responded by
sharon clip of carlson making the claim
to twitter alongside the caption this is
the type of stuff you say when your name
starts with a p and ends with a dejo
okay and referring to the spanish
language term pendejo right is what
she's talking about but
what do you think about aoc and her rise
she's come up she's got nearly 50
million twitter followers and when she
talks she gets millions of views how do
you think that happened she's a
generational leader she's speaking to
her generation i have two daughters my
older one 25 not exactly all in on aoc
but our politics not on that
unlike some of that
bernie sanders type
socialist politics that sounds good but
realistically is ridiculous doesn't work
but she's a generational leader and
she's taken full advantage of the the
new mode of communication through social
media
what she's saying there though is an
example of how these elitists and she's
now become part of the elite she's got a
different
backing but she's part of the elite now
how these elitists
want us to believe stuff that we know
our common sense tells us isn't true
so i mean if you look at aoc
tucker carlos is not altogether wrong in
how he said what she is i mean she's
from the suburbs came from a nicer area
that wasn't raised in the bronx where
she represents
and uh
and
can you say this but she's looks to me
when i see her she's she has
light skin
so she's saying she's a woman of color
but she seems but is is he making the
same mistake that you admitted making
the same mistake when you said that you
were more black than obama she's
light-skinned i think she looks hispanic
yeah i i don't like definitely latina
but i'm just saying this goes down to
the neo-racism weight race card
i know you have strong feelings on that
is that
i'm just putting that out there she
can't she capitalizes off of
opportunities like this she's a total
capitalist you have to realize yeah
except her method of capitalism is
different she capitalizes off any moment
to play the victim card to get her
audience to say
you know he's a he's this and hey
this is why we need to come together
she's a very
very
good young up-and-coming star of a
politician
she's a very good politician you got to
give it to me less than 10 years clearly
most politicians 70 percent i think do
not be how they pull up her age right
now she 32 right now i think she's 32 or
30 um
you know her name keeps coming up
uh uh age aoc age is 32 yeah she's 32
october 13 and she's a libra come on aoc
we're five days apart she's 32. what
does that say about her that
pat is very big in the horoscope
that's the 30 that screws it up okay
because there's no way you're going to
hurt that's balance there's nothing
about her that's balance she's not she's
not one that's willing but is this the
new
politician someone that doesn't bend for
their party that just builds up a
massive social media i mean you can
compare her to being like a jake paul or
logan paul where they're like look i
don't give a about you dana white
ufc i don't care about you boxers i got
my own following i'm gonna go make my
money the people are gonna follow me and
get in line or or don't get in line i'm
doing my own thing it's social media has
been the great equalizer these days look
at her career right now no i think
that's right what you're saying is right
and she speaks for a generation she's
she's appealing and i could see where
people you know would follow her but
i think what chugger carlin is carlson
is saying i i want to defend him only
because
it's my understanding she was raised in
the suburban area
not ex in the bronx in the hood like
she's claiming or she maybe she doesn't
claim it but
and while she has every right to express
her views and
and support the people of her uh
community and seems to be doing that in
many ways because that district as i
understand has always been real far left
um
she's in some ways
what she accuses other people of being
privileged
she's
doesn't come from there and so she's she
has skill and talent privileged side i
get yeah is she privileged that wasn't
she a waitress before this uh
she was working
i think she was working at starbucks as
a
you know barista just like 10 years came
from money or anything like that
clearly the thing they're talking about
the other day she was flying first class
and uh she booked the flight on first
class and
she was getting keyed to say now you
don't want to sit with the common people
you want to sit in the first class with
rich people she's going to get and the
reason why she's going to get that hate
girl from bronx aoc who beat
high-ranking democrat joe crowley faces
questions over her working-class
background after it's revealed she grew
up in a wealthy suburb north of new york
city
uh but this article was like five years
ago it
is one working class clemson a 40-minute
commute from bronx to scholarship but
her architect father uh uh bought a
house in wealthy westchester county in
1991 ocasio-cortez went out to attend
boston university intent
uh intern for ted kennedy yeah there you
go well i stand by what i say that's not
representative of the bronx i mean i
came from the city of chicago i wish i
could have been an intern for a u.s
senator when i was coming up before i
went to college i'm not i don't mean to
say that this is some negative thing
about her but she's
she's had some
that part of the democrat party points
their fingers at white guys and other
people for being privileged
and yet their background is
no different of the very people that
they point fingers at that's that's the
only point i'm trying to say but if
you're asking me she's a new form of
political leader today no question about
it she is and social media gives
people up where whatever their political
viewpoints might be a certain freedom
where if they can build up support like
you've done here with your podcast you
can be a separate individual entity and
independent and that could in the long
run run
maybe serve our democracy in a good way
well the analogy there is like we are no
longer beholden to the mainstream media
exactly or the mainstream big government
if you can create your own lane
like a pbd exactly or like a rogan or
like an aoc the world is yours exactly
today it's
this is the only difference though you
have to realize what's going on today
which is scary
uh today for the first time
40 years ago complainers didn't have the
mic
40 years ago you didn't hear complainers
having a mic we heard from doers is what
it was right
whoever spoke was a doer whoever had the
limelight was a doer today the world is
a little bit confused
because complainers can get up there and
sell a great argument in a convincing
way and recruit other complainers
and
that mic today is very very loud and
they're better recruiters and doers
here's why a lot of times a doer will do
the following here's here's the weakness
of a doer
the weakness of a doer is the doer
eventually goes and says you know what i
don't even want to you know that whole
argument if you are seen arguing with a
you know if you wrestle with a pig you
know
how does that saying go if you wrestle
with a pig you're gonna get some mud on
you yeah you're gonna end up being the
same thing right so so a lot of times if
you argue with somebody that's just a
you know person that makes no sense
others are sitting there saying why are
you even defending yourself right argue
with an idiot and look in the mirror
basically yeah you are theory so why are
you associating yourself with an idiot
so a doer will say you know what i'm
good man i'm going to leave but this
guy's not going to stop talking to
complainer the complaint is going to
keep going going going
and others will interpret that and say
did you see the complainer had a point
he won because the other guy walked away
when in reality the doer just said i
don't have time for you
i gotta go build my business i gotta go
in the arena i gotta go get the hate i
gotta go try to build the
economy so other people can have jobs
and see what i can survive and still
raise a family and still raise kids and
still do all the stuff that i'm doing so
the only difference today with the great
equalizer of the mic
is a complainer with a very um
persuasive way of communicating could
baptize more people into the mindset of
a complainer than a doer
well i don't know because let me give
you a different perspective sure because
nobody
argues and debates with more complainers
than you
you have socialists and communists come
on and you have great arguments and
disagreements with them and one of the
things that you say is let the audience
decide because i would i would classify
a socialist in america today as a
complainer right
but
you're able to have these very impactful
conversations
and yeah they might make a point but
you're oftentimes going to make a way
more valid point and then the audience
can decide who really is the idiot in
that conversation do i have a point
there no you have a very good point
there i agree with you that there are a
lot of like listen take rogan rogan will
bring anybody and have a conversation
with them right and the audience has to
decide uh what they have to say and aoc
today her argument today
is creating momentum because of what's
going on i i can't tell you how many
parents i'm speaking to and they say the
following here's how many parents i'm
speaking to and they'll i'll say so
what's your biggest struggle right now
with your kids oh my gosh my daughter
thinks aoc is her hero
my son
is obsessed with aoc it's their hero
said there's nobody like someone you
know this young person here that's
coming up it's their hero it's their
hero right and and why
they're right you know when you talk to
the kids so tell me why are you why are
you such a big fan of uoc you don't
think these rich people and i always ask
an open-ended questions of these young
people that are between you know 18 17
to 28 years old i said what do you think
my capitalists
con
all they care about is money that's
exactly why aoc is going to go after
them that's why this and you're sitting
there saying got it and they have
wealthy parents and and not necessarily
wealthy parents but parents who are
upper class who are making money who are
going to school you know parents who
parents who tend to believe in
capitalism they tend to believe in
capitalism but they're but their kids
are being convinced by this so
again
this tool social media is allowing
people to convert and complainers
sometimes
so i guess the challenge will be the
following so your question poses leads
to a challenge the challenge will be for
doers to be a little bit more louder
okay just like you yeah you know how
sometimes they say you know uh uh
stop posting these pictures
i'm not gonna post anything okay
that i don't wanna deal with yeah so i
don't wanna deal with it right but you
know what now you have to keep posting
you have to keep posting because we have
to i want my kid to look up to a person
to say i want to go make an impact and i
want to go build a good life and you
realize the older you get money matters
more
it just does
money matters more the older you get
raising kids yesterday we have a couple
with our that was on the we're spending
time with them the afternoon i sent a
video to yesterday when i'm talking to
and i'm doing the face time with your
guy was sitting next to me
and you know the cost of raising kids
today the cost of having a family today
it ain't cheap today to have a family
it's a lot of work to have a family it's
very complicated to have family so
i i just think doers need to be a little
bit louder power to those who are doing
it who question everything well look at
elon musk there's no bigger doer than
him these days and that guy's got the
bully pulpit he and and he is so
incredibly important and another guy
that has to be constantly challenged and
protected because they're going to keep
going after this guy you know respect to
him for not backing down he posted a
picture of the other he's got such a
great sense of humor he posted a picture
there go on his twitter account he
posted a very funny picture the other
day i don't know if you saw it or not it
was a picture of 1980s phone booth
versus today did you see that
go to that picture he posted gotta love
this guy's sense of humor right to click
on that
phone booth in 1992. yeah phone booth in
2022. it's not wrong he is not wrong not
for sure go ahead you were going to i'd
like to do a shout out to another group
of the fellowship of the doers okay i'm
in the trucking industry i work for this
company called cdl 1000 owned by andrew
sapko ukraine an immigrant great
american success story like you
truckers
and the truckers up in canada freedom
fighters these people are hard working
men and women go to work every day they
drive long lonely roads long hours
delivering the food we put on the table
clothes that we wear the building
materials for the houses we live in and
the buildings we we rent from
and now they're trying together to have
their voices heard
in their capital
and they're facing the elitist ruling
class in canada
and yet i do believe that their example
it's frustrating to see how they're
being treated but their example is a
powerful example of doers people who
work hard
getting their voices heard you know aoc
in in that group of young liberals and
complainers as you say what a church
you'll say about young people if
you know if you're not a liberal when
you're young you have no heart if you're
not a conservative when you're older you
don't have a brain
i'm confident history will repeat itself
and our kids including my daughters will
have a little bit more common sense as
they have more life experience and god
bless her for what she's doing out there
advocating for her views
i'm not so sure she's living that
socialist lifestyle they advocate either
is bernie sanders because he's worth
millions isn't he
but
um
regular everyday people forgotten people
solid americans are starting to rise up
parents at school boards
truck drivers and candidates
it is great to see and they're going to
save our country and they're going to
put pressure on their political leaders
who are going to back down because most
politicians are afraid of the people
they don't trust the people and if the
people rise up and recognize they're
being lied to those politicians will
will hear them and they'll adjust so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]